1989 was an auspicious year for human
freedom in the spring Chinese students
occupied Tiananmen Square erected a
replica of the Statue of Liberty and
called for democracy and individual
rights by the fall people living in East
Germany took hammers and chisels to the
Berlin Wall and pulled it down
unleashing a wave of revolutions that
ultimately led to the collapse of the
Soviet Union 1989 was also the year that
Peruvian economist Hernando DeSoto
published the other path the invisible
revolution in the third world which
radically challenged the conventional
wisdom about the persistence of poverty
in the post-colonial landscape this is
what happens when people are helped by
law instead of being obstructed by law
DeSoto argued that people were pushed
into the black market and informal
economy because governments refused to
recognize publicize him promote legal
ownership of property and other assets
without clear title and the right to
transfer property common farmers and
laborers understandably refused to
invest in the land they tailed in the
products they created causing what
DeSoto later called the Citadel's of
dead capital whose riches could never be
fully accessed no one he argued would
plan for the future in a world where
everything you did her own could just be
taken away from you in activists as much
as an intellectual DeSoto has been
called the world's most important living
economist by former President Bill
Clinton he's credited with changing
policy in Peru and elsewhere throughout
the southern hemisphere pushing
governments to create property regimes
that are public and transferable thus
giving people incentives to develop and
build assets for the long term what
works in the United States the most
successful prosperous and probably
democratic country in the world should
be extendable to the rest of the
universe his latest endeavor involves
partnering with overstock.com founder
Patrick Byrne and others to use
blockchain technology and social media
to create totally public and perfectly
transparent records of ownership reason
caught up with de Soto in Washington
miss June where he received the
Competitive Enterprise Institute
Julianne del Simon
which is named for the late free market
economists who believe that mankind is
the ultimate resource Hernando DeSoto
thanks for talking to Reason great to be
here Nick thank you for inviting me
your urine Towns received the Julie now
Simon award what do you what do you see
as the essential similarities between
your thought and Julian Simon's and then
what are some of the big differences I
would say that I'm a disciple of Julian
Simon in a certain way in the actually
in the way that you pointed out about
human beings being the ultimate resource
and there were both probably disciples
of in part Aristotle who said that
potential of anything is bigger than the
thing itself but the reason he said that
four is because we could look at
something and see its potential
potential is how you see something being
transformed into the future and
transformations about combination which
would mean as being both disciples of de
Tocqueville who and this time also said
that America was likely to succeed over
everybody else or every other country
because a the art of combining was the
highest here as well as the laws for
allowing things to be combined and
therefore realize their potential and
therefore didn't matter what kind of the
world what part of the world you were in
you were always gonna make a big deal
out of it you are all we couldn't do
something better because human beings
can transform anything so how do you
feel if you're following American
politics at all we are now and I guess
this is also true in the European Union
there's this real sense that we are you
know we have to close our borders we're
talking about putting up trade
protection parties want to stop legal
and illegal immigration is that a
fundamental you know kind of screw you
to a long-standing not not just to an
American ideal of open borders and
welcoming people but to the very genius
that helped make America a wealthy
country well I think it's disappointing
I think it's disappointing because I
think that Westerners
and quite realized what it or remember
what it took them to become great
countries or why you're Americans that
came from other country became great
when they were the United States there
were a bunch of institutions the United
States which allowed them to be great
wherever they came wherever they came
from
and so one of the things that is crucial
to doing something great is realizing
for example that in the Middle East
there's a lot of people that could be
doing business I mean they invented the
check it was more there were much more
prosperous than Westerners until we
decided to look at Islam instead of
looking where they had the institutions
to do so or not they've got businesses
like bazaars and we don't look at the
mess do they have limited liability can
they get credit do they have property
rights they have none of those things so
here you've got business that also
creates property so it's a pity that we
are have now gone back to instead of
thinking about institutions that is to
say about civilizations and rather come
back to looking at cultures any culture
can become prosperous and it's
disappointing in a way to see that the
West is now concentrating on cultures
instead of what it takes for a culture
to be prosperous what what do you think
is the kind of reset button I have you
know in the United States or or in a
society that starts going down a path to
you know closing things off and and not
refreshing itself and not maintaining
its institutions what are the ways in
which we can say hey let's stop that
Luggin how do we reset this conversation
I think you're really talking about
property rights the thing is that they
came in me watford ago would have called
the anglo-saxon culture they came
through common law common law judge-made
law comes in little bits by little bits
and sometimes you forget where the trend
is but essentially you learn to refer to
manage property privately both as
individuals and collectively as a
corporation as the collective and if you
go to developing countries and former
Soviet countries you will find that most
people cannot access private property
that is to say the capacity to identify
something located and then transfer it
that doesn't exist in most of the world
as a result of which most of
world wants to come to the United States
and those in Africa in the Middle East
want to come to Europe and there you get
all your protections policies and all
your could have been avoided migration
problems so you know your book the other
path was published or at least in
English in 1989 and that was a year that
was fascinating for all sorts of reasons
not the least of which your book but
there was the tmn square kind of protest
and and shut showdown but the Berlin
Wall was pulled down
how has your understanding of the need
for transparent and transferable
property rights changed your native Peru
and Latin America how has it affected
other parts of the world and is the
spread of that kind of your basic
insight that you were just talking about
is it is it really uneven
throughout the world well it is uneven
the good side is that some people like
yourself have obviously read me and
that's that's good the trouble is that
in my part of the world the people have
read me the most are actually on the
Left the left has understood that if
most of us in the third world in the
former Soviet Union are poor compared to
you it has to do something with property
so you will actually see that the people
who go out and title in the Middle East
for example and protect the ledgers that
are homegrown about who owns what
it's the Islamic state it's al Qaeda
it's the FARC it's The Shining Path so
the people that say they read Hayek or
they say they read Milton Friedman or
they say that read my phone Mises in my
part of the world the generator think
about their property and other other
people's property the guys were thinking
of also giving it to the poor so they
can prosper and not be a threat at least
for selfish reasons are you are you
optimistic about Latin America I mean in
many ways since 1990 or 1989 things seem
to be better the the continent is more
stable Venezuela is a nightmare but it's
us
kind you know that in Cuba are the last
truly communist countries so are you
hopeful about your your home region well
yes we have we have made progress there
is no doubt that we follow the
traditional lines we've got lower
tariffs we have more open borders and
therefore we have larger markets there's
no doubt about that we're doing better
but we're still countries of mainly poor
people and poor poverty isn't as we all
know a reason for revolting against the
system unless unless you're not
surrounded by poor people anymore and
you're surrounded by some that are
wealthier you then it becomes a problem
so now there's a second generation if
you want to of of inhabitants of Latin
America were those that are not so
prosperous compared to those who did
become prosperous and I'm fortunate I
think there's still a majority so there
is some danger there we still need
further reforms and they have a lot to
do with who owns the assets and who can
transfer transfer them across borders
not so much who owns them as whether you
are actually certified to own them in
such a way that you can be identified
and cross the borders into larger
markets yes
in 2001 raisin was privileged enough to
excerpt your book mystery of capital and
in one passage you talked about Cairo
Egypt which has stayed with me since I
first read it and you talked about Cairo
as a citadel of dead capital you know
because it's as vast you know tomb of
the once the greatest civilization on
earth and you wrote the institutions
that give life to capital that allow one
to secure the interests of third parties
with work in assets do not exist here
what are those institutions beasts I
yeah I mean there's the ownership title
transferability how do you how do you
get a society what what will it take for
Cairo or for Egypt to revive itself and
can it happen from within or does it
always happen from without no it'll
happen it will happen if it comes from
within it's a big society it's an old
society it's
why society and it did give me a give
you an idea of Cairo about 70% of all
assets in Cairo cannot be identified
through any ledger who owns it you don't
know only about 14% of business
organizations in Cairo are officially
registered and therefore have access to
corporate law what does that mean it
means not that you don't know people's
addresses but you do know where the
addresses are it doesn't mean that you
know you don't know where the buildings
are or the factories art you do know
where they are it means they don't have
limited liability which is that means
that every time they go and make a
transaction it's like a poker game where
they have to put all their chips because
they can't limit their liability it also
means that they can't get credit outside
their neighborhood credit comes from
credibility and they're not credible
outside a small order all that means
they have no economies of scale what can
you do when you don't have scale it also
means that they cannot pledge their
assets when you pledge that's how you
get investment I get investment because
I give you a title or a share - part of
my wealth or my future wealth so they've
got none of the instruments to move
ahead and yet they've got all these
bazaars and they have actually a a class
that in spite of all its limitations all
these this illegal sectors just the
value of their buildings is about three
hundred and forty billion dollars now
when you talk about a rescue mission of
the IMF to Egypt and they say I think
we're gonna put in two billion dollars I
mean obviously the assets that are
needed are right there in the middle of
Cairo but for that you have to be proud
for decide to look at your own people in
a non-traditional way so one of the most
fascinating things I think that you're
working on these days is the idea of
using blockchain technology to create
better more transparent registries and
you're working with people like Patrick
Byrne of overstock.com and other people
who are really invested in in you know
the possibilities of blockchain how
would that work and how will that help
kind of revive these you know kind of
give CPR to these Citadel's of debt
capital well the thing is that it's
American technology new technology can
be a lot of help block change simply
because it can handle an enormous amount
of information and use distributed
ledger systems and have these platform
contracts that are extremely useful but
it's not only that it's for example what
we recently just learned in Peru in
spite of that that's been around for a
long time is that every time we had to
communicate to people that they owned
things but it would be a good idea to
record them in the simplified way is to
actually take a canoe for the next four
for the next four days and then record
etc we now found out that we don't have
to address them 4,000 or 5,000 at a time
I just addressed a whole bunch of them
with one call using Facebook and I
address 2.5 million out of 30 million
Peruvians there's 18 million that
actually have Facebook accounts so we
can put them on google map and we can
use Facebook and you combine that with
blockchain we could get the whole place
going in no time we couldn't do that
five years ago does that and does the
publicity of you know who owns what or
what people are up to does that also
help limit the power of the state to or
the powerful people to just unilaterally
take what what may or may not be there
yes of course the first thing
interestingly enough that they don't
like about blockchain for people is a
poor people don't want to hide what they
own they want other people to know that
they own it and they shouldn't take it
so the fact of the matter and to
actually have a presence so the fact is
that
being legit legitimate and be having a
document is what gets you through I mean
even now that I've come to visit the
United States the first thing I was
asked as I got off the plane was who are
you and they looked at my passport and
checked it three or four times had to
put my four thumps there once you got me
identified I could come into your
country okay most of people in my
country can't do that the idea that is
using a distributed ledger people will
be able you know ownership will be
public and then how do you get to the
point of transfer ability though is that
a you know and you were talking about
transferring across borders and things
like that
what kind of revolution that's that's
not really a technological revolution
right that's more of a political or
social revolution that people are
allowed to own and transfer property
freely well let's put it this way we
have discovered that all over the world
and you know we who are not Europeans
that are not North Americans they're 90
percent of the world have actually
recorded our our assets but as opposed
to yours which are on the internet are
globally available and have been for
some time even before the internet ours
are not so who they are secured by local
Ledger's that is to say that
identification is local so when Indiana
Jones gets to the place he's supposed to
go he looks at the local ledger and he
can identify everybody but he couldn't
have done that if he stayed back in
Indiana right now the thing therefore is
that what you have to do is what
MacArthur did when he went to Japan he
didn't go in and say everybody now can
get title according to the American
system he said first of all I want each
of your individual Ledger's the ones
that are guaranteed by local
institutions of Japan to record once
these recorded and they're inside and
they feel protected because they've come
inside not only as individuals but
protected by their institutions then you
start doing so tightly because people
feel safe if you go and that's why
tightly for programs fail generally when
they come from the west where you going
say I want to consider you as an
individual that come from one of the
Lahaina Mexico but I don't care about
what a lotta come in by yourself they
won't come in because they've got to
come in as institutions once they're in
then you do the D massification but
that's a huge you have in your act
you're asking the conquerer to be humble
and to understand the local place rather
than just tell everybody what to do well
Napoleon did it MacArthur did it you
forgot about in Vietnam and you forgot
about in the Middle East
so remember MacArthur remember Jefferson
remember Napoleon and you'll see that
the magic is easy a final question when
did you describe the moment when you had
your kind of initial insights that you
that your country was not poor that your
people were not poor in that it was the
you know it was the the institutions or
the failing of the structures around
that trapped you know that trapped
people in in an active world but not in
a not in a world where they could
actually govern govern themselves and
prosper actually is when I closed when I
closed a couple of books and opened my
eyes I had associated with some friends
in putting a gold dredge in the Amazon
was I think the first one and with a
gold dredge so it's you you the water
flows through and you pick up a little
bit so it floats in the middle of the
river and you just dredge and we did it
with some Bolivians and Rio Tinto's Inc
unfortunately we did it just when the
price ago started coming down but we we
didn't even really make money we just
ended up even but I hadn't seen it
because I'm not a miner
I just was in charge of trying to see if
we could get some funds and I brought in
some of our funders and we started going
down the river who was supposed to be
our concession it's a property right and
as we went down the river we started to
you know there was some gold washing
plants on the side and I asked our
manager for these guys are in our
concession he said oh these are called
chichi cables these are you know like in
the California Gold Rush bunch of guys
the long beards and they're panning the
gold and watching the gold and they just
kept on appearing as we kept on going
down the river and so our German
Bester's I said you know why don't we
kick them out if this is our place and
the manager our manager said well
because of the dredge we're 50 and so
far in our concession we've calculated
that there's 2,000 of these outlaws then
I started realizing that most of us in
the third world were outlaws and then I
started saying what does it take to
actually get a concession I saw that we
had took three law firms a whole bunch
of guys and most Perez don't have three
law firms and don't have the cloud and
don't have the contact and this when I
realized that market economies weren't
only just about freedom there were about
good institutions well we will leave it
there I want to thank you we have been
talking with Hernando DeSoto he is the
author of course of the other paths in
the mystery of capital and he's the 2018
Award recipient of the Julian Julian El
Simon award given annually by the
Competitive Enterprise Institute
Hernando DeSoto thanks so much Thank You
Nick for a reason I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]